babes I am on tour right now with the
guys tickets are available on
impracticaljokerslive.com a bunch of
cities up there cities always being
headed later on in the month we got
Green Bay Milwaukee Rosemont then we're
heading over to Seattle Portland where
we head to the show uh so on and so
forth Bangor Maine extra show in Boston
is added all right now on
practicaljokerslive.com and the show is
on every single Thursday night 10
o'clock Eastern on TBS and TruTV all new
episodes season 10 check it out we love
you babe
I appreciate it New York City Radio City
Music Hall sold out in just 10 days on
September 22nd so we've added a show
September 23rd at the theater at Madison
Square Garden those tickets are on sale
at christycomedy.com New York City come
on out most of my shows thank you so
much are sold out the ones that aren't
are Fort Myers Florida coming up in
March 16th next week
um then we have March 29th one of the
shows at West Palm Beach has tickets
available uh Austin Texas April I'm
sorry no that's sold out April 13th San
Antonio Texas we have tickets available
The Late Show May 5th and buffalo has
tickets May 6th and Ithaca has tickets
and
um that's it so I appreciate it go get
the tickets in New York City theater at
MSG it's gonna be fun and we got special
guests and I'm not going to tell you
you're just gonna have to see it to
believe it and might have a show on Vice
to town it's called the super maximum
retro show every Tuesday 10 p.m Eastern
Time
uh
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey baby
[Music]
it's hey babe hey babe what's going on
we have a guest today in the house my
good friend Buck Angel
Google Buck Angel [__] Angel this is
Buck Angel everybody oh is it the guy
that married the sex uh no this is this
is a very famous uh Chris Angel's male
uh female to male uh porn star that you
remind me of that was a female that's a
female now it's a guy Buck Angel bro I
was a female yeah you were a female yeah
that guy's ripped yes so is tank Sinatra
who's our guest everybody wow
12 years old I spent three months just
[__] do it just trying
wow 12 years old you had to have
at 12 years old you had you had
pectorals like that
I had tits I mean I had I was I just
because I saw pumping iron and I became
obsessed with being able to move my
muscles yeah well you've I know well
you've moved it something else for me
yeah I didn't want to see it uh
oh look Peck pop and flexing chest tool
this is what tanks this is who tanks are
natural language it's a tutorial yes
how could they tell you how to do it I
could have used that when I was but not
everybody
do it you have to have a certain muscle
in the PEC everybody can do it I mean
listen if you're completely flat chested
there you go
you're popping them you're popping what
are you doing what are you doing to do
that
I'm uh what I'm thinking about now is
I'm but I'm my I'm telling my brain to
move my pecs towards each other
yeah you gotta have a good mind muscle
connection to start with I don't know
but it doesn't work like yours well mine
are bigger it's listen if they're
they're moving do you do that
do you do is that like a a little tick
not a tick but like is that something
you just do whenever no would you say
you do it every day no okay no do you do
it sometimes and catch yourself and go
oh [__] I was doing it
no I mean it's always that well it's not
something that ever just flexible okay
so you have to thoughtfully and you have
to think about it and do it yeah but I
mean I think very little because I spend
so much time perfecting my craft when I
was a team right okay but you also
aren't but you are on steroids oh yeah
that's not good that's bad that's good
no tank will tell you that it's not I
told you we're gonna have tank on to
talk about I'm here to talk to you about
steroids crypto watches and Costa Rica
okay
and your new board game out on Amazon
influencers in the wild the game go
places gain followers get famous no
Talent required influences yeah
we were gonna play the game we were
gonna play the game on the show but he
brought the wrong box because he's a
meathead yeah I brought the Chinese
prototype and it has covet in it yes
Chinese prototype came here in a balloon
oh I don't want to expose you guys to
that now um let me ask you so so many
questions can you educate
I said please let me come make Sal's
head explode just by like the things I
love yes it's gonna hurt you and I can't
wait because remember last or two
episodes ago I tried to explain to you
why HGH and testosterone all those
things were good but I didn't do a good
job of explaining to you well uh uh tank
now can tell you what can kind of say it
the right way okay
basically and that's what I love about
influences in the wild the board game is
they tell you what steroids are okay
through fun and laughter yeah we're
educational we want people to be
educated and not willy-nilly about their
steroid use but if you you know right if
you want to jump on some juice I could
admit let's this can become a 20 20. I I
have so many questions from steroids
would I benefit from steroids yes and
yes yes so the the reason you do them
solely solely is just for Mass yes just
for Health it is attached to it no
because you told me there was one only
one study that all we've learned about
stories is based off one study that
wasn't even really that thoroughly done
well you it's not ethical to perform
steroid experiments on people so they'll
do them on animals but when you when I
say steroids I say it kind of
tongue-in-cheek because like anybody who
does any kind of steroids is on steroids
the steroid is a hormone so there's
corticosteroids and anabolic steroids
like you know I remember watching um
bigger stronger faster this is when I
decided to do it I trained naturally for
20 years I watched bigger stronger
faster a documentary by Chris Bell and
he's talking about performance enhancing
drugs and the whole baseball uh Scandal
or whatever he's like what's the
difference between a pitcher getting a
cortisone shot in their shoulder and
somebody taking testosterone I agree
pitcher who's getting the corticosteroid
shot in their shoulder could not throw
the ball if they didn't have the shot
how is not how is that not good before
it's enhancing you know what I'm jumping
on juice honey
I told my wife and she was like all
right good you're gonna be [__]
jacked but why are you guys jacked
already let me you are back it up I was
yeah how often do you have to do it once
a week and do you have to and how and
how long perpetuity I mean I'm ready you
just do it forever inject me twice
before I go in the ground so I have so
you're just gonna do it forever
[Music]
you're just gonna do it forever it's a
hormone so so there's people now who
Vera like uh semantics is very funny to
me the topic because people go he's not
on steroids he's on hormone replacement
therapy that's steroids brother that's
steroids I call those people Democrats
so you're on trt testosterone
replacement therapy what do you want to
say about the Democrats I just want to
say this is a politically neutral show
and I just uh uh I I hit everybody
equally and Trump 2024. yes uh not Trump
you are the picture of uh uh apolitical
a political you don't look like you have
any associations I'm wearing a I'm
wearing a sweater a sweater like I'm a
black man in 97. yes right exactly you
got to even out that face that's why
that's what it is that's what it is so
um steroids inject it's a very big term
like sandwich like there's a thousand
different types of sandwiches okay but
the bets come from Joey Rose's sandwich
shops right on Rivington Street for all
your thorough needs go to Joey roses on
Rivington by the way the sandwiches last
night at the party phenomenal yeah
[__] awesome yeah we've been talking
about it really good I sought him out I
didn't know if he did the sandwiches
there or not but they were so good I
figured they had to be yeah and I asked
them I'm like did you guys do the
sandwiches and he's like we did and I
was like they were [__] good and then
they got like an inch taller yeah for
the viewers at home we're not pulling no
they're the best sandwiches at the best
price if you come to New York City you
go there don't don't [__] around yeah
they were they were really good so yeah
so bread the bread's softer than tank
Sinatra if he wasn't on steroids yeah
that's right Pillsbury baby okay you
take take your first steroid yes how
long before you're like oh I see a
difference see a difference yeah
um feel the difference
I mean the set listen when you've
trained naturally for 20 years right the
second the needle enters your epidermis
right you feel [__] like things have
changed whoa it's different now that
instant because now you're uh so and
it's I don't do drugs per se like right
well you're sober you've been sober for
years 20 years yeah inside steroids
besides steroids which I have four they
don't break their sobriety
personality into changing or like
um what's the word mood altering sure
we'd be in a different conversation what
about Roy Bridge
Roid Rage is more I'll be honest with
you I see him very reserved he's the
most calm Zen person you've ever met in
your life he's like he's like Buddha if
he was on steroids reject yeah
um prednisone you see so you not road
rage you have like Road inner peace
yeah we're peace um prednisone is the
only steroid that's ever given me Roid
Rage
why did you get mad
anybody
[Laughter]
my stepdaughter was calling for my wife
from the basement and I got annoyed at
it I don't know I don't remember it's
something like that and yeah wow that
seems like no real reason at all but
prednisone is nasty for for your
personality testosterone actually made
me feel more like okay because I think I
had low testosterone at like 32. but
that doesn't doesn't that also make it
bad what taking testosterone no taking
the steroids doesn't that lower your
testosterone it lowers your endogenous
testosterone which is your the
testosterone your body produces but you
replace it with the shot
okay so you're good but then you come
off of it who comes I don't come off of
it okay okay it tickles my balls yeah
your testicles um they're okay okay but
I have a friend who's on test time
everything's good there who's on
testosterone and he has to he has to now
because he got testosterone surgically
implanted into the crease of his ass oh
yes he have this guy he this guy he has
to now give blood uh I think every two
months he has to take a pill so he
doesn't developed hits a pill so he
doesn't go bald which you didn't take uh
hey hey and then uh and then um
something else some type of like skin
pill so there's all these things that he
has to do so what do you say to that so
that type of testosterone the
bioidentical capsule they put in you is
supposed to be very good I don't have
any experience with it but that may
raise his estrogen sometimes it raises
estrogen sometimes it doesn't it's
everyone's different but as far as
donating blood goes
um every male should be donating blood
every two months really no matter what
even if you're not on steroids 100 why
just because of blood clotting
um because every time you lose a pint of
blood you get a new pint of blood made
from food water tissue in your body why
would you not want a new pint of blood
what if you have AIDS oh it's like an
oil change yeah they say that I mean
that was we almost blew right past that
if you have AIDS you should not donate
blood even if you're a man I just want
to say that
um no matter what uh no matter what the
degrees well because vanity is very woke
and she thinks that aids blood should be
you know also considered well they used
to have question
they used to have a question on there
that was updated recently
um that would ask you if you had sex
with a man within the past six months up
until like two years ago yeah I remember
checking yes and what does it matter
what do you care
okay so all right we gotta give blood so
you and I have to give blood that's
something we should do but the the the
but because what it says here on the on
the website let's get Let's get someone
here live on the pot no I was gonna say
should we do that for one of the next
episode should we get give blood and
also get an IV drip on the show I would
love it okay not at the same time
because that Ivy might be hit and
different if you have a pint less of
blood oh wow let me ask you this so do
you so so and what steroids when we say
testosterone is that considered a
steroid yes oh yeah is that the only one
you're on you're finally saying test I'm
so proud of you he'd asked me about
tests I'd be like who's this fat
Southern lady you're referring to yes
how does it enter your body through the
muscle so you do an intramuscular shot
it gets into the bloodstream which to be
honest with you I went to go get
testosterone from a doctor he did my
blood work beforehand he's like the
doctor gave it to you yeah it's legal
yeah it's street legal
mandatory dude it should be mandatory
testosterone for most people
you look at like what's going on with
people and how you know down and sad and
depressed and tired and [__] fat and
no sex drive
you know I'm right here
if we have the technology why not every
why doesn't everyone feel like they're
27 for the rest of their life do you
feel like you're 27 right now 25. I
could start taking it but then you got
to work out you can't just take steroids
and not work out that is so that's the
when testosterone hit the mainstream and
there was the the commercials with the
Umpire who's like strike and then
they're like get AndroGel that was like
people were taking it you don't remember
that commercial no it's a very famous
commercial and then like people who were
a little bit too old to be as jacked as
they were would show up in the gym a guy
with a very tight shirt and abs and
white hair like a walking Viagra pill
comes into the gym and um they were not
changing their diet not exercising and
not donating blood and some of those
people were stroking out because they
were unhealthy anyway wow so
testosterone increases your red blood
cell count so you should donate blood
but you should be donating blood but
once you donate blood you're that that
all you got to do is do it once every
couple of months and you're good
if I take it do I have to like start
doing crunches right away or can I just
take it and not do that take it donate
blood go about my business well do you
exercise now no why not because I bought
a Peloton to be honest I buy vegetables
I throw them out after two weeks yeah it
doesn't do anything yeah I threw the
Pelton after two yeah no I no I I just I
should fit it into my not regular not
like natural like I'll go for walks
that's great you know but like I'm not
like in the gym no no a walk is exercise
to clear that to be clear about that as
long as you're moving your body then I'm
a beast yeah I walk everywhere you're
good you're good to go
so okay so you all right so but and then
in addition to the testosterone what
else do we take
I don't recommend anything just
testosterone yeah you're advocating for
his tests I'm not even advocating well I
guess I am I did Justice
you want to take it I want to start
taking well you joke about taking
Winstrol when you were in high school
oh you took testosterone when you were
no I took nothing I make up stories oh
okay because stories yeah so Winstrol
will dry you out big time
um increased risk for injury Trend will
make you homicidal so there is there's
there's a steroidable tread which people
have a tough time with same thing with
uh is the word out about that Trend yeah
among people who know yeah for sure
homicidal Tren Anadrol you just get
[__] why that helps in the gym if
you're a single guy who's dedicated your
entire life to Fitness and you have to
be jacked because your life depends on
it and you're a bodybuilder and all that
do whatever you got to do but the normal
person who like has a job in case vanity
has just updated her dating profile no
trash
I have a question what's up what's the
best time of uh what's the best time of
day to do steroids there's no there's no
do you have a favorite time of day but
what's better like like from a body
point of view what would it be better to
do in the morning there's there's
absolutely no time uh restriction like
you don't have to do a steroid and then
get in the gym within an hour no they're
used they're taking every day at the
same time no no once a week like my
blood pressure medicine yeah shout out
losartan yeah potassium yeah yeah
potassium 50 milligrams I was on it I
came off it why move to something else
okay stop working [__] all right so I
gotta check my blood pressure yeah yeah
how's your blood pressure now I'm on
medication but it's controlled yeah same
hereditation but it's hereditary my dad
yeah my whole family's on blood pressure
medication except for me which is weird
because I'm on steroids wow
you gotta inject yourself up yeah of
course
you switch it up shoulder yeah rotate
spots whoa how is it like what how long
did it take for you to overcome the fact
that you had to inject yourself with a
needle two seconds two seconds yeah it
was not I donate blood I've been
donating blood since yeah but that
doesn't mean you know how to do it and
you don't have any any Hang-Ups on it
like you still got to pierce your skin
and go into a muscle I'll be honest with
you it wants to get really sore because
you could you could do the wrong thing
and [__] yourself up bad right yeah you
could yeah every once in a while I'll
I'll [__] load it up and then I'll
just leave it a bit I don't feel like
stabbing myself right now it's just not
in the cards for me mentally yeah so
even now it's it's it's it's a thing
that you have to like
be in the like be ready for sure yeah
because sometimes all that time eight
out of ten times there's no problem
whatsoever okay two out of ten it's like
I hit a nerve or something so two out of
ten is a lot for me 20 20 of the time
you're hitting a nerve
or something it's just not a great
injection
planted into your the lower crease of
your ass that's brand new I don't know
why you keep saying crease and I think
it goes on the side no it's literally
the the the crease the lower fold of
your ass that will hang out if you if I
throw it if I throw in a pair over here
not everyone you're talking to Chrissy
crease yeah not everyone has a crease I
have a nice round
um right but I'm saying that's where you
they just make a little slit yeah and
that's what and then they put the pills
and they sew you back up yeah that to me
putting it in there for six months is a
lot that's a big commitment because then
it's like there's nothing you can do
it's in your body if you take
testosterone and you have a problem with
it it's out of your system in 10 days
what about those patches
can you just do that like a Nicorette
yeah like a Nicorette yeah
don't don't they don't they
don't they what's Nikolai teslan Tess
um no he was not he was on Adderall who
invented Tess
Russians I think right yeah they're the
most Drago Drago yeah he was [__]
jacked I mean he's I watched Rocky IV
recently with my son have you seen it
recently no as someone in this political
climate dude when Apollo Creed comes
down and he's like yeah
deserved it
but Ivan Drago was jacked but he's but
you look at him now as an adult and
you're like oh he's like a buck 80. he's
not that big yeah I can't kick his ass
shredded no defense Rocky movies yeah
yeah
250. oh nice and that's what you want to
be no I'd like to be 230 but can you
lose weight on testosterone yeah sure I
just can't stop eating it's not what'd
you eat today uh so far I had a Lenny
and Larry's cookie salted caramel
chocolate very good I don't need them
all oh that's a protein cookie it's a
[__] cookie I mean it's touted as a
protein cookie but yeah Lenny and Larry
know what they're doing they know what
they're doing they made a good cookie
and um two orders of egg white bites
from Starbucks okay Double Toasted like
I tell them to make it look like a
marshmallow you know here we go
testosterone was first synthesized in
Germany Germany Tank's Hometown uh in
1935 and was used medically to treat
depression professional athletes began
misusing anabolic steroids during the
1954 Olympics when Russia weightlifters
were given testosterone so interesting
testosterone treats depression as you
said of course yeah so you feel like you
your mindset is different better for
sure how do I know I'm a candidate
um get your testosterone testosterone
checks and if it's low oh that's the
only way though no but you yours wasn't
low you still got it uh it was low it
was low for my age it was like 300 okay
32. what should it be six seven ideally
you want to be around like seven or
eight hundred what if what if you
already aren't seven or eight hundred
then what will they give you tests
anyway then you don't need it then you
go on Trend and then you go to jail and
then you go to jail then yeah murder
suicide your family here we go this
downside to this right there's got to be
downside well they just pumped Us full
of that in our heads and it's not well
Lyle alzada who was on the Raiders best
famous story
um blames his brain cancer on steroids
and it's like bro I mean I guess yes you
try to make sense of a tragedy in your
life right but testosterone does not
cause brain cancer it doesn't cause any
kind of cancers there's no link
whatsoever it does increase your red
blood cell count and it does make your
body stop producing it that's it
so but so that's why so the studies now
long term huh long term anything
long-term bad
um do they have the research I mean HGH
although this is somewhat of an old
wives tale they say that because
um it increases the growth in all of
your cells in your body if there is
dormant cancer cells it can kick start
that but we don't know if that's true I
mean the doctor that I spoke to said
there's no research to support that but
like it mentally it makes sense it's
like a like when people say not to eat
carbs at night because you eat them
during the day during the morning
because you'll burn it off it's like I
don't know anybody who's a farmer who's
burning off carbs all day long right
most people sit around yeah but it makes
sense tank was the one that told me you
know your body doesn't work like on such
a matter of fact schedule like I thought
you you know we've heard all the time
that you got to eat protein within one
hour of exercise of working out or else
the protein's not going to get into your
muscle and bubble and he was like that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard he
was like it does not take if you drank
protein five hours after you worked out
it's the same thing as an hour there's
no reason to take it immediately if you
want to take it immediately you can but
you don't need to yeah because your Bot
and then that made sense to me because
like why would our bodies be working on
a 60-minute schedule they're not he'd be
dead yeah they're not our bodies it's
just it's just the protein companies
made that up a lot of things what I
think when I speak of when we talk about
this health and fitness stuff a lot of
things are just kind of um they did
studies and then you know were paid for
by certain lobbying groups and then we
get all this info that we take as fact
and then it's this whole thing happens
but really some of the things that are
healthy for us that people say are not
it's just because there was money
involved and there was campaigning
involved yeah so that's what it is go
back to that Nazi thing pimp I want to
read this so 1940 1945 according to
anecdote anecdotal like go back to that
Nazi thing dude the Nazis the Nazis
tested anabolic steroids on prisoners
gestapos and Hitler himself testosterone
and its analogs were used by German
soldiers to promote aggressiveness and
physical strengths retrospectively
according to his physician Hitler's
mental state toward the end of his life
exhibits characteristics that some
scientists associate with heavy steroid
use Mania acute paranoid psychosis
overly aggressive and violent Behavior
depression and two-sided I know that
doesn't sound good so was Hitler on
Trend he was also on meth like way more
than he was a truck a lot that's what it
was well he was getting injected with
meth every three hours
you don't know about that do you know
about that no son every three hours the
Nazis take this thing they're called the
tank chocolate Panzer chocolate which
was meth it was crystal meth in chalk
the Nazis invented crystal meth and they
would give it to the soldiers and then
they would do the blitzcrag and storm
Poland and put people in case they were
all on meth that's why from Hitler down
because it wasn't called meth you know
it wasn't like oh we're sucking dick for
this it was where this is the this is
the drug that makes us super superhuman
Jesus but apparently from what I've read
he was being injected with it which is
another level of uh absorption in the
body like there's that famous video of
him at the Olympics in there like this
that's because he was they put him on
meth uh he was on tons of meth but if I
mean meth makes sense that leads to bad
choice super aggressive yeah caffeine
any kind of stimulant like I I was
drinking I have a monster here white
monster I was drinking so much caffeine
that I started to hallucinate and I told
my therapist I'm like I cut I cut down
caffeine I'm doing like one cup of
coffee a day or tea or something and he
goes well yeah there is something called
caffeine-induced psychosis I was like
thanks for the [__] heads up dude I
was ready to jump off a building
caffeine too much of it 100 increases
anxiety can induce psychosis so wait
you're you train you're a healthy guy
yeah you care about your body decades to
an extent I mean if there's listen well
my next question is that I'm surprised
you've thrown out of your Bot it's
delicious and certain things like I'm I
was listening to the the most recent
episode I don't know if it was um taste
buds or hey babe but the [__] Q-tip
like I'm a Q-tip in the ear as often as
possible sometimes when I put it in
there I wish it was made out of metal so
I could really yes right now so I can
really scratch sometimes when the swab
itself gets loose yeah and you're
getting just that you feel the tip of
the stick and you hear it sharp yeah no
no but I'm saying you know like when the
tip of the like the tip of this like if
the cotton comes a little loose yeah and
you get the end of the stick which is
like a little rough I feel like scrape
them oh my god dude the audience is
coming right now so if there's a disease
that's caused by Coke Zero I'm getting
it don't care right it doesn't matter
like certain things I just I need I love
Coke Zero now your your natural resp
yeah has that always been there do you
smoke is that like you have a raspy
voice is that just oh natural so
sometimes it depends I don't want to
ruin anybody's perception of my voice if
they think it's cool but when I was
waiting tables at this restaurant I
waited on it was a charity thing I was
like oh I'm so happy to be here like
internally to help these people who are
uh unfortunate and disillusioned
disenfranchised youth from the city sure
and this girl goes yo why does your
voice sound like a munchkin and
everybody laughed at me I was like [__]
these kids
your voice you can get voice over work
like that's very that's that's a very
you're one of those guys you hide behind
Your Meme account but you should put
yourself out there you got a hot voice a
hot bot a nice watch you're a [__]
steroids are you not show yourself on
your account no idea yeah a little bit
Yeah
I do the videos the board game is I mean
board games in on Amazon in Target it
just got put on Amazon so let's talk
about that let's talk about it because
tank put up a lot of his own money yeah
let's oh yeah I'm in a lot of trouble
tank said he's saying a hotel last night
because he came out from your party was
really because his wife threw him out
because he put up all the money on the
board game so go buy tanks board game
because or else he's going to start
taking Trend and he'll kill you and my
family please wait take me to tank
Sinatra was was that did you just decide
that when you started to do you think
you got it from Frank Sinatra yeah is
that what you got it well I mean
obviously
I'm big it just it protect your nickname
before no it was like a T-Bone from
Seinfeld situation but it worked out oh
someone someone called you T-Bone no I
no like George wanted everyone to call
him TV all right George and you said
tank and they called you I I made my
name
that was it tank Sinatra I'm big I have
blue eyes and from New York it's a
memorable name and what's your real name
George Sinatra very German rash George
hush Rush that just sounds like a bunch
of confidence you spell it n-a-z
yeah that Rush is means uh crystal meth
in German yeah
um did you by the way just see that
video pimp can you pull up that video
again of the robot it's pretty scary
because it's making me think look at
this robot look at this road look no
that's ex machina look at our life look
at what our life
watch how creepy this is look at this
look at this this is the world our
children are gonna live in I've had
enough I've heard enough for talking
about this kind of thing man I'm getting
massive massive daily anxiety look at
this well you need testosterone to help
the anxiety look at all that is oh nah
what do you guys think do you think some
of the people out there that I think are
humans are robots and they've been
robots for like truly no you think it's
part or you think we're living in the
time where robots will assimilate into
society well I think people who are down
to modify their body might go full rope
would you go full robot
um I would that the whole nurse should
go full robot I would if I could live
forever and decide when I wanted to die
because I have no desire to live forever
that's a very long time
um I would you know if I could let me
back up there was everyone thought I was
on steroids when I was younger because I
was jacked I was like I'm German and
Irish I [__] worked out got carbs
whatever and this girl from college goes
are you on steroids just tell me and I'm
like no I'm not on steroids I used to
get insulted that was people ask me if I
was you used to be it was that girl from
college yeah then you cut your hair
um it's so funny because my friend Eddie
I would ask him what he says if people
ask him if he's on steroids he goes oh I
get insulted and I'm like oh yeah why
he's like you can't [__] tell should
I take more like what can I do yeah but
when you're not and people ask you if
you are you go no I'm not and then you
get insulted and she's like I don't
judge like if there was a pill that I
could take that would make my body look
10 to 15 better I'd [__] take it and
I was like oh okay that's interesting
but I didn't do it for another yeah like
that for women but we have it yeah yeah
right like we you we can take like if a
woman took there's no testosterone
equivalent for like a woman start taking
more estrogen it's not not it's not
going to do anything no that's like a
reflex activities a breast cancer drug
like breast cancer drugs like uh I
forget the name of it let's uh being no
it's not like yeah I forgot I've got the
letrozole letrozole is uh something that
bodybuilders use to reduce their their
estrogen but it's like way too much it's
Overkill you must have a tailor on speed
dial though
Pursuits yeah
um I actually I'm gonna legs are like
redwoods my legs are big yeah so they're
just Flex them involuntarily yeah look
at this look at this progress.com
yeah like I mean you're not just picking
that shirt up off the rack are you no
this is a rack shirt but once I find a
shirt that fits me you buy five pair
is that a double XL or an XL double X
wow and it's tight like a tiger yeah and
what size are your jeans like I could
never dress like you guys like I wish I
could just most can't pull it off be
normal
yeah you're right it's tough for people
to pull off a hoodie
you can never do this bro
no but you can go shop at like normal
places I went to h m 15 years ago put a
shirt on it was a double XL it was like
comical yeah how small h m though
they're they're both that's [__]
European guy yeah the shirt was like
three bucks so I was like yes I'll wear
it yeah I need this yeah so so do you
ever feel trapped inside your own body
like you have to keep this look up yeah
I want to be a woman so bad yeah and I
couldn't get that not to change Sexes
but do you feel like I have like I have
a friend who knows John Cena very well
and he says John Cena every day like
when he's on a movie he said
contractually every day has to work out
in the gym for two hours it is part of
his contract it's part of a shooting
schedule he has to do that because he
has to keep up what John Cena looks like
in order to be cast in the movie roles
and be play the part of John Cena so I
wonder like does he feel trapped by that
or does he there's no way he looks
forward to it because my friend said I
see him in the gym yeah and he isn't
happy doing what he's doing he isn't
happy he eating you know a piece of
grilled chicken and celery he's he's not
happy being jacked well it's probably
more the food thing because working out
is something that people do because they
can't not most of the time like I can't
not work out you don't work out today I
did not work out today you only did do
100 push-ups in your in your uh hotel
room I did some push-ups yeah just uh do
you not feel like yourself if you don't
get the workout in no I can skip I can
skip because here and there it's not I'm
not psychic does your wife work out oh
yeah oh so you both have that in common
then I got her the Lululemon mirror for
Christmas oh yeah yeah loves it yeah I
heard it's cool but then again it's like
I don't trust it well you think they're
looking at you work out looking at me do
anything you think they're watching well
don't set it up I don't think they turn
it on when I start to do jumping jacks
you think I think they turn it on when I
get up in the morning and I'm walking
around with a morning erection too well
you got a phone and a laptop I mean if
people really want to see you they can
but most it's it's
most people don't want to watch us live
our you know our boring life I'd be
surprised
I have a question for you I was on a
practical
have you seen the whole Joey swole viral
video of don't don't film at the gym
yeah what do you think of this yeah what
do you think of Joe we swallow because
I'm interested with him why is he is
people about shaming people at the gym
well here there's this video where a lot
of women are doing videos saying men are
staring at them in the background okay
and then this guy stands up for himself
saying don't film in the gym I don't
want to be on your camera
Sal babe yeah let me tell you something
the nights are getting longer but the
breeze isn't the only thing that's
getting stiff that's right wow this
episode sponsored by bluetooth I love it
I you know I I take one uh listen I take
them and I like them and their Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA and uh we
all know we all know that that
confidence can take you far in life it
can especially true in the bedroom right
okay uh you need to step up to the plate
that's where Bluetooth comes in and what
your ass you might you know if you're
living under a rock let me take my
erection and move the rock for you
Bluetooth has the same ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
and the best part is this is all done
online no visits to a doctor's office no
awkward combos no waiting line at the
pharmacy the Bluetooth comes direct to
your door in a discreet package but baby
there'll be nothing discreet about what
Bluetooth can do for you
left well here you go Blue yeah
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and they're prepared and shipped direct
to your door that's it baby and all you
got to do right now is go to
bluetooth.com put in that promo code hey
babe you're gonna get a your first month
free go to bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode one more time bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe at checkout all you
got to do is pay the five dollar
shipping and you get that first month
free so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
chew it and do it have better sex
doordash is just I mean we can't
literally get enough of doordash I I
think I use doordash every day of my
life I use it at least once I use
doordash multiple times a week I have
two phones the app is on both phones
here's the thing with doordash if you
love the convenience of getting what you
want right to your door then door Dash
is the place for you they'll get grocery
delivery stock up for the week last
minute Cravings whatever you want did
you burn your last piece of toast I know
I did did your avocados gone bad it
happens is the hot sauce bottle empty
yeah it is try grocery delivery from
doordash everything you want delivered
right to your door and if you want even
more value you can save on all your
grocery and restaurant favorites with a
zero dollar delivery fee on all eligible
orders with a dash pass membership I
love that they give this membership out
I love it doordash is the best and right
now with our promo code you will get 50
percent off yourself half first off your
first door Dash order up to a twenty
dollar value when you use the code hey
babe23 at checkout that's hey babe23 at
checkout all you got you're gonna get 50
off up to a twenty dollar Min subtotal
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code hey babe
23 everybody loves the number 23 I love
Michael Jordan okay and uh limited time
offer terms apply don't forget that's
code hey babe 23 for 50 or your first
order with door day
he met Joey swalls allegedly
when I was when tank Smiles his skin is
the same color as his shirt purple baby
purple baby you look like Grimace yeah
you look
look that's sour or people are just
smiling in your face all day long
um did anyone ever like give you an
attitude of course really oh yeah some
people are wild they do I know they
don't happen so when I was competing
um I met I I just did a video on him for
my Natty or not
um Snapchat tile Natty or not meaning
are you natural or are you not exactly
on steroids are you not obviously the
guy's on steroids his last name Saul so
um is he open about it no I shot him a
message and I said hey man big fan this
is when he was doing shreds on Instagram
which is a really long time ago shreds
was the supplement company that there
was a whole Scandal around and him and
Paige Hathaway and the same way for the
documentary on Netflix this guy Arvin
Lau uh started the company he was like
the male face of it so I shot him a
message I said hey I know you work for a
supplement company but I'm competing I'm
just wondering what your you know your
hormone regimen is because we have a
similar build and you look [__] great
and I'd like to try and emulate it I
don't know much about it and immediately
he's like [__] piece of [__] don't
ask me stupid questions like that blah
blah blah oh yeah instantane like the
First Response it wasn't like hey man I
don't really you can't it sounds like
that sounds like Trend yeah maybe he was
on Trend at the time yeah
um so then he's like I'll reach out to
Steve uh Weinberger who's the head of
the NPC and make sure that you never
compete again I was like I don't give a
[__] dude doing a show in Brooklyn for
for fun I want pictures I'll go get
pictures anyway but you didn't ask him
anything yeah you just asked him you're
actually asking how you he you can look
like him because you look up to his body
but the implication was that like he's
obviously on steroids so tell me what
kind of steroids you take and help me
but who am I whatever
um so when I see him he's but even back
then he was doing that like oh I'll hold
the door for people and I'm such a nice
guy and I'm always Jim CEO of gym
positivity
I see that type of person who is like
super you like I don't want to say her
name but an Ellen type of person say her
name say her name whenever you're around
me say baby yeah
well like everyone else should be nice
all the time but the rules are different
for me right not saying she's nice or
not nice but like she became associated
with kindness and synonymous and
whatever and generous DeGeneres yeah
it's just funny to me that he
is having a Resurgence of of sorts
because he's saying hey like he's
telling people to do [__] what he's
telling other people not to do just one
degree away so they're shaming the guy
in the video he's shaming the girl in
the video What's the difference right I
see what you're saying yes it's a
vicious uh Circle yeah he's gaining the
clout and and a notoriety off of shaming
the girls who were shaming the guys like
how are you better than the girl in the
video I don't know I don't know if I
what can I hear what Joseph said let's
hear what Joey swell said because I want
just I have just seen this still in the
video and I I'm gonna DM and ask him who
does his eyebrows because I like him
video yesterday I made a response to it
but when I went to post it she had taken
the video down which shows me that she
listened to her followers that were
defending that man and she wanted to do
better but then today I got tagged on it
again she reposted it put it back on her
page so here's my thoughts first off
this is not harassment sure he could
have been a little bit nicer but this
man is not harassing you and this
doesn't make him a Karen you know what
this makes him the other 99.9 of people
that are in the gym that don't film
their workouts in our influencers you
have to understand that just because
you're comfortable filming yourself your
body to post on something though amen
doesn't mean I can't stand and people
just turn it one of the number one fears
that so many people have and the reason
they won't go to the gym because they
don't want to be in somebody else's
video you also have to understand that
your filming is never a priority over
somebody else's right to feel
comfortable they pay for a gym
membership if you use that space and
they should never have to wait to use a
machine because you're filming a video
so to this young woman you look great
you have a large planet sexual
harassment I hope you decide to do
better
[Laughter]
yeah what does he do what is he doing is
that Alan Finn the comedian the grizzly
bear
laughs
what is what did he say he asked to use
the machine is that what happened no no
she had a sorry she's having sex with
the with the machine yeah and the booty
is she's humping she's humping the
machine so he's like hey are you having
sex with that because you might like to
have sex with it first or could you just
hump me maybe he's saying maybe he's not
well I don't know what he's
no he's she's filming he sees that he's
in the video he says hey would you mind
not filming I don't want to be I just
think the gym should charge more money
to anyone who's making content in the
gym you should just have to pay double
sure well I think that doesn't solve
that problem though no but at least
they're paying for the right to do that
but the person or have a gym have
certain gyms that specifically say you
cannot use your phone anymore like a
smoking area there are a designated
filming area they're always says that
you keep no filming it typically says it
in the locker room but people film in
the locker room too and then someone
will walk into it and they'll say hey
can you not film in the locker room and
then Here Comes Joey swole hey man just
because you're filming in the locker
room doesn't mean that somebody else has
a right to feel on shut the [__] up this
guy sucks I see right through it you
like him great Sal happy for you no I'm
kidding no no
I I mean he sold me there can only be
one big bald guy and that's really nice
Joey swalls Joey swalls bought influence
influencers in the wild the game well
how do you feel about that he bought it
I like him yeah I like him now let's get
into it so in the game he's only got the
Prototype okay but I can I mean listen I
mean you have nothing in that box I
could I should [__] in that box and put
there's needles and testosterone oh boom
love it so listen here's the thing you
travel around this board game you start
here you go to Coachella you go to Bali
the the honeycomb the influence the
spots the influencer spots Tulum if you
go to fire Festival you go back to the
middle of the board you lose a hundred
thousand pounds is that for real oh yeah
I love it but when you land on these
spots you gain followers or lose
followers so if you land on the no Wi-fi
sign you lose a turn if you land on the
low battery you lose a turn and then you
end up at the pink wall which is like
the mecca of influencers listen I just
have to say I've seen some reviews it is
fun people are like oh there's no
strategy involved it's like this is a
stupid [__] board game game that you
should play Drunk strategy it's not
Dungeons and Dragons it's influencers in
the wild it's a silly fun time right
that's all we're having to do is trying
to be silly Willy and sell some games
and there's challenging to keep his
house yeah and I'm gonna lose it it
Shoots and Ladders does that have do you
want to [__] lose all this money do
you want tank to lose all his money get
on Trend and kill Joey swole
because that's what will happen if you
don't buy the game who's going to
protect the female influencers if Joey
swell's not around actually how are you
doing with all the Bitcoin stuff because
you're the one who got Chris into
Bitcoin right um I'm a long-term holder
holder baby so he's a holder I'm good
I'm good to go I'm not did you sell it
no I didn't sell I didn't tell I deleted
my coinbase account
that doesn't mean anything no I know but
I'm saying I don't want any part of I'm
not buying selling it's just there so
I'm a holder so you know your password
right yeah yeah yeah you hold them you
hold them bro you hold him hold him wait
so hold just to to wrap up the game what
do you mean
I just quickly want to say though just
real quick before we will get back to
the influence in the wild I just want to
say I literally I've noticed I don't
know what it is I've noticed from last
week to this week and practical jokers
ratings have to be double maybe triple
because of how many I'm walking past I
was walking the other day I was walking
it was whatever was nine ten o'clock at
night I was walked past an apartment
building right here on Third Avenue and
I saw 100 of the televisions on had
Impractical Jokers yeah really the
ratings are going up we have been
trending up which is nice we're trending
up which is good which is what really I
would think the heads of the networks
want to see and what they have to be
seeing
Thursday nights 10 o'clock on TBS and on
True TV all new episodes season 10 out
right now you gotta watch it where would
TruTV be without Impractical Jokers it's
unclear do you hear that everybody over
at Discovery and won a media yeah I
think um I think it would be um it would
not be around it would not Breaking Bad
in a like a e was not doing great yeah
um all right go ahead so no I just I
just so you can see either who did you
work with on it like how did like is it
just 100 that's just you so myself and
Adam Padilla Adam the Creator on
Instagram okay Adam small on Instagram
Adam shriveled on Instagram and um you
you linked up with a manufacturer or oh
yeah yeah so we so we were on the phone
one day and a lot of meetings at 10am 10
p.m or 11 p.m Chinese manufacturers so I
said bro what if there was a game uh
translate no we just [__] if you do
so in that promo code hey babe you'll
get a nice discount babble.com
I speak you know a couple myself okay
say something in another language say um
okay what yeah the hell was that what do
you want me to say in Spanish but I took
French for six years and uh
[__] myself
my friend Chris rest in peace not you
obviously you're here he's dead like
True TV if there's no practical jokers
exactly he made this this protein
ricotta cheese called Promise a protein
ricotta cheese it was delicious fresh
with protein yeah how did we die Chris
killed himself oh Jesus Christ what can
you do yeah was it because it's been hey
babe
yeah
no there's just I mean it's just there
so the game listen we were on the phone
one day I said what if there was a game
where you traveled around to all these
dumb influencer spots and you racked up
followers instead of money we started
masturbating on the show on the phone
together because we were so excited and
then we started laying out what it would
look like I am I've never made a game
before I don't know how to make a game
you can tell because nobody's been
buying it
it might suck I don't know
with actual like Instagram accounts like
so that factor in or so you pick out an
influencer playing piece the girl in the
yoga pose the guy [__] lifting
weights or whatever all these different
influencer demographics and then you
travel around and then there's if you
land on a blue spot you pick a card and
those that's where like all the fun is
there's challenges in there oh uh
questions like actual challenges for the
people playing like do your best
um give us a 30 second hustle and grind
motivational speech so like people are
getting I see the things that people are
posting and I'm like you guys are not
having fun doing this why why and then
I'm like because it's uncomfortable and
cringy to [__] record content in
front of people but that's kind of the
whole point right the whole point is for
you to see that you grabbing a bag of
chips and saying hi I'm ABC and this bag
of chips really does the trick use promo
code for whatever like that's one of the
challenges grab a piece of a thing of
food and become a food influencer
instantaneously that's cool I like that
but there's only like 10 of them so we
didn't want to overload it but I think
um we just got to get some better
content and how can people get the game
is good I I have the game I play the
game my family the game is great the
game's excellent it was just about it
was only a Target but now it's on Amazon
which is why everyone it's so easy to
get yeah Target Amazon it's on sale on
Amazon you know you got it into Target
yeah how did you do that because he's
[__] Joey small helped him yeah
this podcast sponsored by betterhelp we
love better help we both do it we're
both on it I've been on it for uh two
years you know the pandemic I got
involved that's better to help yeah
right it is awesome Getting to Know
Yourself can be a lifelong lifelong
process especially because we're always
growing and changing therapy it's all
about deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way we do until we talk through things
and better help what do you love about
better help well it connects you with a
licensed therapist you can take you on
that journey of self-discovery from
wherever you are you can connect right
away uh you don't have to go to an
office you don't even have to show
yourself you don't completely discreetly
you can do it completely naked that's
right it doesn't matter you get signed
up with a therapist right away
um and because it is not just local
you'll have access to Specialists and
therapists that you wouldn't have maybe
where you're from and right now all you
have to do is go to better help that's
help
betterhelp.com hey babe you're going to
get 10 off your first month so you just
go discover your potential with better
help go to betterhelp.com h-e-l-p slash
hey babe 10 off your first month mental
health is serious go get it
that's insane yeah if you know anything
from watching anything if you watch
Shark Tank you know that real estate
shelf real estate Target especially in
the board games I think Mr Wonderful
would invest in you yeah they hooked us
up Target hooked us up but it was also
Target spending was down 30 across all
stores last year wasn't probably not
agree but how did you get the meeting
um through a broker that we used and you
pitched it to the powers that be like
who desire a Target she was like we love
it we want to we want to put it on uh on
shelves for next holiday season and then
they called back they were like we
actually want it sooner we wanted Q2 I'm
sorry Q3 and then they were like we want
to put it on yeah uh we want to put it
on an end cap we want to do this and the
ilf faces outward thank you but then
what happened was I got I mean we
launched it and it launches
it's supposed to go up
um
without disparaging anybody the launch
was a bit of a disaster like I got a lot
of messages from people who said I went
to three or four different targets and I
couldn't find it and is it here or is it
you know where is the reason it wasn't
in every Target it was so there was two
people off the target one yeah they
missed the target please
[Laughter]
cap is actually cut out everything but
that yeah it cut out 57 minutes the uh
the end cap is actually not a great
place to be I found why
um because if I tell people go to Target
and look at you know what what's
happening you look like Alex Murdock oh
geez
because why because that's where they're
looking for all the board games no one's
looking for it separately is that what
people are looking for it next to what
do you mean Cards Against Humanity and
they're missing it on the end cap the
end cap is good for people who have
never heard of us and don't aren't going
to Target specifically for that reason
yeah they walk right past the end cap
because it was in between E.T the game
and Godfather of the game that's not
where you're looking for it right so
without sounding like I'm making excuses
it's on Amazon now and it's still in
Target you can definitely go to Target
and get it I gotta be honest with you
though if the people who are messaging
you that it's not in any of these
targets yeah they're stupid [__]
because it clearly says influences in
the wild the game so you just have to
know how to read the other issue which I
think is the bigger issue is that a lot
of The Targets in metropolitan areas New
York La Miami Chicago Austin are smaller
and they don't have a game section so
most of my followers are Instagram
demographics they're not in Kansas or
you know right there's nothing around
for 30 miles right so it was you know so
we're learning experience game section
would be like next to the betting no it
wouldn't be in in the store at all ah so
there's like eight 1920 Target stores we
were in 1800 of them which means there's
120 stores
yeah and that's probably what you're
saying congratulations thank you yeah it
didn't work out but thanks no and now on
Amazon I mean anyone can get it yeah I
mean Target is uh everybody will get it
you'll catch this everyone will get it
and you'll like it if you play it with a
a loose way about you and you're not
like serious about it and you know it's
a board game you can play for fun yeah
have fun with it don't get too like
caught up in what's happening like if
you get um one of the penalties is like
your dad found your only fans lose 50
000 followers right that should be a
good time
it's not fun who the hell is playing
listen here's what the hell is playing
it the other way who's like my dad found
my only fifty thousand
here's what me and my family have been
doing we have the game we've actually
bought two and we found that when we
imagine it's Cards Against Humanity we
have a great time exactly
exactly I have no problem with that no
I'm kidding no I literally I I do have
the game I never played Cards Against
Humanity but influence in the wild my
daughter Delilah she loved it but you
but now but now she's uh she's gonna be
on the path to an influencer which at
first we were upset about but now we're
like that's where that money is baby do
you think a lot of money dude my son has
been making Roblox edits on YouTube
really oh yeah and he's crushing it he's
having a great time wow yeah bro there's
like
my son my friends kids they're twins one
they started like twitch accounts or
whatever yeah and they're eight yeah
right and then one of them got a video
that got 1.8 million views it's insane
he's not on it but he's like walking
through the video game and talking and
can we start putting our dates at the
end of his videos yeah
from that he got 2 000 subscribers he's
eight that's insane yeah I mean good for
him yeah but it takes a lot of uh I
hesitate to say it takes a lot of work
because it's it if you say that to
someone who's like waking up at 4am and
going to be an electrician for seven
eight hours it's a different kind of
work what we do but still requires
diligence totally different I mean
you're always thinking about work you're
never off the clock because is that your
soul drop the game or the Instagram
stuff yeah yeah and when did you make
that shift
um end of
2017. so a while yeah it's been a big it
was a big decision to make it bro if it
lasted you I would have yeah
do the Plex again
you should just do that you should just
have influences in the Wild on your
packages bouncing around I swear to God
yeah if it lasted a year I would have
been fine if it lasted two years I would
have been fine I mean I'm my life is a
dream it truly is because you stumble
into it but I mean we're you haven't
been on this show no you have not so our
our listeners tank Sinatra is a meme
account yeah honestly they know they
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I've
been to his house Tank's got a nice
house yeah so do you thank you and did
you stumble into that
um it was like it was like the sixth or
seventh thing that I've tried so it's
not online yeah I had blogs and video
blogs and [__] you know but um it was
deliberate and accidental because I
wanted it to happen but I was like I was
ready to sell fence for the rest of my
life I didn't care okay I was I sold
fence for a living I worked in
restaurants I've had
[Laughter]
well when you're attracted to me
everything sounds sexual isn't that
right Chris it's very true yeah and uh
you could see tank uh he's the slowman
shields guy
okay he's in a big red shirt and if
you've got a slowman shield tank Sinatra
oh you're the guy I got a Michael
chickless a young Michael chickless
thing I know yeah you heard it oh yeah
yeah I mean can we google Michael
checklist uh the commish
yeah yeah and then he was the also the
thing but a young Michael Chiclets yeah
but he's not on test Michael checklist
no like when he was young yeah yeah look
at that so him every white guy that's
played a cop on TV for the past 20 years
basically Hank Schroeder uh hurt from
The Wire who I made a sketch with
actually came out oh Dominic um
yeah he's awesome yeah great actor and
he's I mean he's taken food out of my
kids mouths but uh yes oh yeah because
you always got his roles oh yeah every
time I see him in a movie I go to my
wife I'm like that should be [__]
that should be okay do you also Act
no not really I did a commercial but I
joke like every time there's anybody
who's over 200 pounds and somewhat must
you learn a movie board game is not a
joke though it's serious board game is
serious influencers in the wildgame.com
or Amazon or Target go get it here's the
thing guys don't be annoying if you buy
it just have fun just buy it have fun
tanks uh invest a lot of money in it and
we're gonna you're gonna go buy that
game or tank is gonna live stream his
suicide on his own Instagram
and this has been hey babe
[Music]
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]